hey everybody welcome back to pokertex a
taste of Adventure today we have a very
special scenario it's called Celeste
mountain and the description of this
scenario is that it's a mysterious
Mountain that's rumored to have magical
properties a strange old man is willing
to cheaply sell you land on the mountain
so long as you develop it into a
thriving theme park to draw extra guests
to his hotel now some of you gaming
aficionados might already be noticing
something here this scenario is actually
an Ode to another game it's called
Celeste and it's a beautiful platformer
and one of the designers who worked on
Park attacks Gabby actually worked on
Celeste as well I believe she made the
3D map that you navigate the game with
specifically and in Architects she works
on a bunch of UI stuff and scenery items
most notably in my opinion many of the
trees that made their way into the game
at some later stage and are some of my
favorite trees to use as well so this
scenario was made as kind of an Ode to
her and to Celeste the game as well and
just getting this out there Celeste is a
platforming game but it's absolutely
still one of my favorite games of all
time even though I'm not a platformer
person at all it's got a beautiful art
style amazing gameplay and most of all
importantly in my opinion a really
amazing storytelling so I highly
recommend checking it out but for now
let's check out the scenario and see
what we can do with this in architect
so the map of Celeste mountain is based
on Celeste mountain in the game Celeste
obviously and it features many
references to all the different chapters
in the game I'm not going to point out
too many of them because I think it's
just gonna spoil some stuff that you're
honestly just gonna have to find out
yourself if you haven't already and if
you have played the game you might be
able to recognize some stuff
um but this I suppose is worth pointing
out the tutorial level the first part of
the game features this little house and
a bridge
and some Shenanigans happen over there
and it's how we make our way into this
map over here now I haven't even talked
about the uh goals of the scenario which
don't look too difficult we just need to
get 800 guests into the park I'm not
gonna bother anymore with all of the
non-optional goals that
um would that force you to not uh
unpause the game to force you not to
pause the game I mean sorry
um because obviously I'm not going to
make that anyway uh and then we have 200
guests in the Park which is an optional
goal that basically just gives you some
extra money once you pass it and
um obviously I also never use blueprints
so I might get that one but you know the
other one completing everything by year
three I also think I'm not going to get
there but notably getting to 800 guests
in this scenario isn't as easy as it is
in some other scenarios something that
you might not know is that every map has
its own uh difficulty level in terms of
how easy it is to satisfy the guests and
how easy it is to attract more guests
and Celeste mountain is one of the most
difficult scenarios in that sense and if
you've played this scenario before
you've probably noticed this so it's
going to be a little bit more
challenging than it appears to be at
first plus we have a very limited amount
of land now obviously the local hotel
owner is willing to to let us buy some
land but it's going to come at a hefty
price so it's 20 dollars per tile so
even just buying 10 tiles is 200 uh
buying 100 is is well obviously two
thousand dollars that stuff starts
stacking up pretty quickly once you
realize how how many tiles you really
need to expand into this whole area so
with all that said I'm not going to go
too heavy on the theming I also think
this is not one of the most easy maps to
theme either I'm just gonna see whenever
I end up coming up with but um I'm gonna
focus on building some good roller
coaster layouts that seemed like the
most fun Challenge and we'll see how we
can fit into the pre-existing theme of
this map which is a little bit difficult
somewhere along the way so let's get
started
so I just realized that at the start of
this video I forgot to show you guys
which rides we have available to start
off with in this scenario but honestly
you guys didn't miss out on too much
because it's not a very impressive
selection but it does have one
particular coaster which is going to be
a very good money maker or at the very
least a much better Money Maker than any
of the other rides that we have
available so far in the game and that's
the eurovighter or the vertical drop
coaster as it's known as in-game and
um I thought this time let's try
something special and something I
haven't tried before and build a dueling
eurofighter not just because I figured
it would be fun I think there are two
other good reasons to do this one of
them is uh simply because it's it's a
great way to get even more guests into
your Park and get an even larger income
and at the same time be very careful
about how much space I am using up
because I do realize that I am using up
most of the flat space in my available
land for a coaster which is usually not
the best strategy because that's where
you generally want to place your flat
rides but right now this is the best
land that I have available on the map
and I think starting off with two
coasters with a good excitement rating
and a hefty price is going to be really
important in drawing in those guests not
to mention coasters are better at
drawing in guests than flat rides are
and because we need to get to 800 people
in this park and they aren't the easiest
people to please over here it's
important that I build enough coasters
so I figured this would be a good start
for that reason and the second reason is
um kind of related to the lore of
Celeste because there's a main character
in the game and there's an antagonist
which is based on the main character and
they have a very interesting combination
of color schemes as well and I figured
that nothing would be more fitting to a
Celeste themed Park than to have dueling
coasters built around the main character
and the main antagonist
um so yeah that's especially uh fitting
I think for the lore and for the kind of
functionality of this park as I try to
make it into a successful scenario it's
also kind of fun because having those
two vertical lift Hills right next to
each other and dropping down into that
first you know completely symmetrical
part of the layout with the two Loops
it's just kind of satisfying it is what
it is building dueling coasters is is
just just extra fun to look at and to
build it just takes a lot of time so you
might be noticing that I'm already
taking quite a while to make these
layouts if I think back on when I was
doing this it definitely took me way
over an hour to record this because
generally my videos are sped up to the
amount that and an hour of in-game
recording results in five minutes of
time lapse so you can generally
calculate back for most of my videos how
much that is going to uh well yeah
translate into a real-time playtime if
you will
so a lot of the challenge of building
dualing courses like this is trying to
make the timing right and this just
means that you have to do a bunch of try
on error and one thing that Park Tech
does that does make this a lot easier
than other theme park games is that you
can test coasters starting from the
Block breaks which is really handy
especially in this case because I am
trying to fit in well quite a lot of
block breaks just to make sure that we
can fit enough trains on this layout
because eurofighters only seat eight
people per train and I do call them a
train they really look like vehicles but
fun facts about these things uh both
rows of these little trains
um have their separate uh like wheels
and they can rotate
um independently of another so they are
really just two car trains as much as
they look like single vehicles
um but yeah that's that's not very
important now the important part is that
they have a very low throughput so
putting lots of block breaks on the
layouts allows us to run four trains on
these things which is allow which is
going to allow us to run them with a
very good capacity and
um I'm not going to spoil just how much
money these things are going to make but
honestly I'm pretty happy with how that
turned out and the decision to add those
extra block breaks was a very important
one so if you ever find yourself
building one of these in Architects uh
for realism's sake but also for your
money's sake do make sure to give them
lots of block breaks in this case I also
gave them two separate stations so that
we can have an unload station and then a
load station
which saves time because people can
unload very quickly and then the car can
go to The Learning Station so it's just
making the whole operation just as just
slightly more efficient and at the same
time it gives you an extra block so
that's one more extra vehicle that you
can fit on your coaster technically I
could even fit five trains on this
coaster with the amount of book breaks
that I have but that would result in
trains having to stop every now and then
and that's something that I don't want
to do because you also want to make sure
that none of the trains have to stop at
any of the block breaks unless some kind
of emergency is going on which is
basically also what it's like in real
life the best operations allow you to
fit the maximum amount of trains on the
layout without the trains having to stop
anywhere where you don't want them to
stop or having to wait too long in front
of the station for the train ahead of it
to clear the station
so that's basically the layouts of these
two coasters all done
and now I figured it was time to add
some flat rides and some scenery to this
area first thing I decided to place is
this little the cranky thing here I have
no idea what this thing is called what
is it again it's
um
whatever it is it's a pretty cool and
small flat ride and it has a good
excitement rating and it fits underneath
the coasters in that spot over there so
I was happy to place it here because the
rest of the flat area in the park I've
already filled with lots of Tangled Trek
mess so all of those spots are
definitely out of the question
um also this location over here doesn't
destroy too many supports and I
definitely want to keep these coasters
somewhat realistic in the supports
department so this location it is and
um given that this flat ride is quite
tall I didn't want to place a roof on
top of it but I definitely wanted to put
a little bit of scenery around it and
after a long time I'm thinking what I
wanted to do with this scenario because
the scenery of the scenario is
based on Celeste which means that if you
add anything it it already kind of feels
out of place and you can totally just
change up the scenery of this scenario
completely I saw Studio KV do North
Korea inspired build which was very fun
to watch a very interesting theme I
suppose
um but whatever you think of the the the
real life implications of that I think
it was a very creative take on this
whole map and trying to do something
completely different with it which I
kind of toyed with in my head as well
but eventually I ended up deciding that
you know if we want to stick to the lore
of the game realistically I think the
hotel owner that is willing to give us
some money to develop this park would
also want to want us to to put a lot of
effort into making this park fit in with
the general look of this whole area and
kind of Tidy it up a little bit as well
because something tells me that the guy
is is is probably fond of us trying to
take this mess trying to take these
ruins and making them a little bit more
friendly to the eye and making them a
bit nicer to look at so I'm going to
stick to the theme of the game and of
the map and I'm mostly going to draw my
inspiration from what is already there
in the map
um but I am gonna make everything look a
little bit less abandoned and terrible
while at the same time keeping most of
the structures intact because
um I also don't feel like destroying
everything so we're just gonna take
these structures that were once lived in
and try to reappropriate them in some
crazy theme Parky and sense
um that's basically the plan and um yeah
that's uh oh yeah I also decided to
build this uh this drop tower over here
because yet again it's a flat ride with
a small Footprints and many other things
are not going to fit in here plus I
think it would look good from the
general uh well perspective of walking
around in the park to have this Tower
right in the middle of all of these
ruined Towers uh that's the tallest
tower so you kind of have that pyramid
Skyline shape effect where you have one
tall tower in the middle and then
everything kind of becomes a little bit
smaller as you go further away from that
um I think the same actually goes for
the towers that are inevitably gonna be
have gonna have to be built for the Euro
Fighters lift Hills because those things
are gonna have to fit into the general
look of the structures around them as
well but I think that's gonna work out
fine you know we just have a new bunch
of extra Towers in an area with already
many Towers now when it comes to the
station I decided to give it a
completely different style because this
is not an old abandoned building like
many of the ruins that we see around
here but instead you know it's it's
something new it's something that we
built just for these roller coasters
that just so happen to inhabit these
ruins so I'm just going to build a fancy
new building and mostly ignore the
abandoned style of the buildings around
them
and particularly I was inspired by the
color scheme and architecture from one
of the levels in the game
which takes place in a kind of Asian
area at least I suspect it is which has
to do with the name of said character
but also the roofs that you can see in
the level design they do have those
those typical Japanese moves so
I just I just thought I saw a very good
excuse to yet again do some Japanese
architecture because it's it's always
fun to do and in this case I'm taking
the color scheme from the game and from
the particular level which has a Kind of
Blue issue to the Rock work it has dark
purple roofs and
um wooden structures with kind of
reddish tint to them so the color scheme
is is very much lifted from the game as
well which the same goes for the color
scheme of this map in general lots of
purple most of all and Jason's colors
some red some orange some magenta and
then some uh colors as well some Hues of
blue in the Rock work and the trees
obviously a lot of green as well
um so I am still trying to fit into the
general look of this park you know it's
a very different type of architecture
and it's a type of architecture that I
think would fit into the lore of the
game um but at the same time the color
schemes and everything I'm still trying
to fit them into the ruins that we're
working in here and trying to make those
a little bit nicer to look at
um so as for the architecture itself
um it's not too much interesting to add
I suppose I've already done so many
Japanese builds before in architect I
did take a trick that I saw from some
other build and
I'm afraid I forgot who made it uh so
this is going to go uncredited so I'm
sorry for that
um but I saw this idea of making the the
wooden brackets that support the roofs
with the square basic shapes which that
square basic shape can be used for
basically everything in park Tech
because this is mostly textureless game
and yet again it comes in clutch to make
these wooden structures that little bit
more believable and when I added the the
Finishing Touch of adding the flag in
front of the roof at the facade on all
sides basically there I felt like that
was just the perfect Finishing Touch and
it really reminds me of the banners that
you see at the entrances or under the
roof lines of Japanese buildings that
are typically show what a building is
like so for example in a bath house
you'll have this this this cloth with
the bathhouse symbol on top of it in
front of the building and adding a
little touch like that I felt would uh
finish the building and also give it
just a little splash of red and make the
building not too purple to look at
because it really is a lot of purple uh
looking from up here finally I decided
to finish the support structures for
these Euro Fighters and that is
basically it for this first part of the
video we've mostly filled in what land
we have to start with and the park is
running very well so let's quickly take
a look and see how it's going
all right it's been about two years and
I don't know if you guys noticed by
looking at the bottom left but these two
coasters are some insane money makers
more than a thousand dollars a month and
there's two of them so with just these
two coasters I'm swimming in cash
already which is pretty good uh being in
year two and having twenty thousand
dollars in the bank I'm afraid these
things are too good honestly this this
might be getting too easy I really
thought this was going to be a difficult
scenario
um but still I think it is going to be a
bit of a challenge to get 800 people
into this bike without it looking like a
complete mess so I'm gonna try and see
how many more rides I can reasonably fit
into this space and that's mostly going
to feature building different roller
coasters and I'm already very intrigued
by the tilt coaster because that thing
is very underappreciated so I really
want to play with that thing
um maybe an inverting spinning coaster
but I've already done those in other
scenarios but for now let's quickly do a
POV of these coasters
um
yeah unfortunately we're just gonna have
to get this car there we go
so most of the cars are filled with
people which is also pretty good so
we're running a good capacity big cues
over there so we start off with that
synchronized drop into the synchronized
Loops which is just too satisfying to
look at and I think we might be getting
a little bit of a race here because I
have noticed that different coasters win
depending on the weight distribution
sometimes orange winds purple winds a
little bit more it's definitely not 50
50. but it is a race every time
um but it looks like purple is going to
be yeah purple is going to be winning
this one and I think decently
comfortably too but still it gives
really good interaction you can see them
doing their thing next to each other for
basically the whole layout with purple
ending with this extra Helix as an
element and orange having that extra
Corkscrew if I had to give a preference
for which layout I would personally do
honestly I'm not really sure I think
purple has a more interesting first half
of the layout uh especially having the
slightly faster s-bend thing over here
because here we have that part where
both of the trains do an s-bend and then
they get around and find their way back
to this uh mid-course block section over
here
um but orange might be the better layout
overall honestly
but it's it's a tough call but I think
this Corkscrew with that sweet Hang Time
with the other terrain passing
underneath it is uh going to be the
deciding factor for me there
um also I think the color schemes work
surprisingly well together and I really
didn't choose these color schemes they
are just based on the color schemes that
the characters have in the game so yeah
it just works really well even the blue
supports on this orange coaster I think
actually looked pretty Alright and then
the the colors for the cars are the same
as the supports basically so blue cars
in this one and very dark purple cars
over here and actually when it Banks you
can kind of see that they articulate
separately so you can see that they're
really trains of two cars instead of
just a single vehicle which they often
look like but yeah that's just a small
roller coaster fact
and then uh here we see how the rest of
the park is doing
but honestly it's not too much yet so I
think it's a good idea to just keep
going and see what else I can come up
with let's go
so while I start building a new part of
the park I want to say that I'm trying
my best not to spoil anything that
happens in Celeste because I really
really recommend you guys to play the
game but at the same time some of the
things that I'm building in this
scenario are inspired by Celeste by
particular characters or things that
happen so you know it's uh it's a bit of
a challenge to see how I can vaguely
talk about stuff without alluding to
anything too specifically
um but you know that's all part of the
fun of doing a scenario like this it's
also in terms of the Aesthetics maybe
not my favorite scenario to work on in
Architects I think there are definitely
scenarios that look better in scenarios
that I've been able to make better
looking things out of but it is
interesting how it's very different from
everything else
um so there's that and a lot of it is
also with me trying to adjust the
scenario to the look of Celeste Celeste
plays in wintertime and you have lots of
snowy levels there are many gray colors
a lot of white mixed with lots of very
saturated bright colors like pink orange
and
very light colors of green and blue the
game definitely has a very particular
color scheme and I'd say it's a it's a
huge contrast between very saturated
bright colors and saturated warm colors
so a lot of greens and blues mixed with
oranges yellows pinks and reds which
basically you know gets you to most of
the colors that we have in the color
spectrum but the game manages to achieve
a very particular look with them and
it's what I'm trying to emulate a little
bit with this scenario so if you take
for example the color scheme that the
tilting coaster has right now which is
the basic color scheme that it has in
the game it's not really fitting with
the Celeste theme so I'm definitely
gonna recolor this at some point but for
now it's just to work on the layout and
see what kind of layout we can come up
with and also I wanted to build a
tilting coaster because I haven't built
too many of these things especially not
in the scenario mode and they're really
fun to work with and because we have a
scenario that's very hilly obviously we
are trying to build on the side of
Celeste Mountain here I think it's a
good setting to experiment a little bit
with the tilting function and
specifically having it tilt in an area
where it's very
easy to see from the paths you know the
whole tilting action and have the rest
of the layouts
be somewhere down the mountain a little
bit further away from the paths but in a
space where you can do all kinds of
inversions and stuff and then we climb
back up the mountain to the station
which is quite high up and I think the
fun part of doing layouts like this is
that you get to have a first half of the
coaster that plays out before the lift
Hill so you go from the station straight
into the action and then the lift Hills
kind of at the halfway point and in this
case the drop is kind of at the halfway
point the the tilting drop and after
that you basically have some of the some
of the most intense and exciting
features of the layout
um at the end of the layout and I guess
you also have some of the most exciting
features at the start because you have a
drop out of the station and there are
very few coasters that do this kind of
thing in real life time traveler comes
to mind in Silver Dollar City which is a
high up station and a vertical drop out
of the station and I think that sort of
stuff is really cool but really only
possible if you have a very hilly
Terrain and um I think tilt coasters are
a good candidate to make use of that
hilly aspect of the layout
also fun fact the Tilt coaster exists in
real life but there's only one
application of it but technically there
are more
um the company then invented them the
coma only Built one in Taiwan it's
originally called Gravity Max it might
still have that name I don't know if it
changed names or themes in any ever
since it was built but they've built one
in Taiwan since then some Chinese
knockoff companies have made some
tilting coasters as well the reason why
I'm not sure if I would consider them to
be
full-fledged you know 100 pure tilting
coasters is because they don't tilt
vertically I do know somebody who's been
on them and supposedly they're pretty
fun
um but it feels slightly different from
what this tilting coaster offers and the
fun part is that the coma is developing
more of these things so we're gonna see
some tilting coasters appear uh
elsewhere in the world which is pretty
exciting because I feel I feel like it's
a really cool coaster concept that is
super underutilized and we definitely
have the technology to build more of
these things
now moving on from the tilting coaster I
decided to give it a color scheme that
fits a little bit more into the Celeste
Universe
um I decided to build a launch coaster
and this layout was way too easy because
I just built this thing already and my
commentary is lagging behind
um but yeah this coaster is inspired by
um you might have guessed it I believe
it is called the speed monster in uh
Tucson food in Norway which has a very
signature element it's called a
Norwegian Loop in real life it's called
the Norwegian Loop because well it's
built in Norway
um but it's very similar to a pretzel
Loop and it's the first element that we
see on this coaster here
um
I don't know what else to say about it
but it's just a really cool element and
a speed monster in real life manages to
have a kind of Meandering layout on the
side of a hill and I think this coaster
does more or less the same so I was a
little bit inspired by it I also managed
to fit in that cheeky overbank turn that
shoots out of a very busy area down
there with some buildings and it flies
underneath the brake run of the orange
Euro Fighter and over the final Helix of
the pink Euro Fighter
um a stuff is definitely kind of tight
over there but it felt like the most
logical way to finish the launch coaster
but yeah we have lots of interaction
between different coasters here which is
always fun
and aside from that it's going to get a
pretty well
minimalistic theme I would say it's not
going to be themed after anything in
particular in the game but we'll get to
that in a second first I wanted to
figure out what to do with this flat
space of land over here and flatland is
very rare in this scenario and for once
I decided to actually put it to good use
with a flat ride because otherwise I
feel like this park would have way too
many roller coasters in comparison to
the amount of flat rides but it is
pretty tricky to figure out where I can
fit those things in
so after I decided what to do with my
path work over here I decided it's time
to theme the tilting coaster and to do
this I came up with a kind of new way to
do sort of rock work walls and that is
to take lots of basic pieces and slap
them together into a kind of cobblestone
texture and I say Cobblestone because it
reminds me of the Cobblestone texture in
Minecraft which is also achieved by just
putting a bunch of a bunch of squares
next to each other in slightly different
Shades of Gray and really that's all I
did in this case as well but I think in
architect it actually manages to look
pretty convincing especially if you mix
up some of the sizes as well as the
colors of the of the squares and also
add some little blocks here and there
and some rock work around it and of
course some of those dual kind of Shard
things that you see all over Celeste and
it manages to to look like a kind of
convincing rock structure that looks a
little bit man-made but made out of
natural materials if you will and I was
such a fan of this thing that I
originally wanted to use only for the
the well foundation I guess I should
call it of the tilting mechanism but
eventually I figured this is just way
too good of a material not to do more
with so I decided to just use this thing
throughout the scenario and I'm just
gonna see what else you can use it for
so maybe buildings maybe terraforming
who knows I'm a really big fan of how
this thing manages to to work and
especially when you blend it with other
scenery and with foliage as well it just
looks pretty convincing and it's very
easy to turn it into different shapes as
well because it's made out of lots of
basic shapes so you can basically build
anything out of it that you want so I'm
definitely going to experiment with that
a little bit more and one of the first
things I wanted to experiment with is
creating little plateaus of grass where
I could put some foliage because one
thing that does irk me a little bit
about the scenario and the way that it's
built is that there are very few green
spots there's very little grass in this
scenario which makes sense because that
is basically what Celeste looks like and
then what it is based on but in park
effect it means that we don't get a
whole lot of color variation there's a
lot of gray and white on the screen
right now and I figured I would just
need more foliage along with some of the
more bright saturated accent colors to
make this whole scenario look a little
bit more colorful and make it more
interesting to look at and at the same
time I didn't want to just throw random
swatches of grass everywhere I forgot
what I was talking about because I just
got a call but you know I'm just gonna
keep going
um but yeah So eventually I came up with
this solution just putting a bunch of
grass on the hillside and adding these
Rock structures to make it look like
these are really man-made structures to
make this whole thing a bit more
interesting and add some extra foliage
and especially maybe some some colorful
foliage and flowers here and there
um not sure you know exactly what this
would be the what the purpose of this
stuff would be realistically but it
looks cool and I figured that's the most
important part of this whole business
and it all meant it also manages I feel
like to make this Plateau that I've
built for the coaster station and the
tilting mechanism it manages to make
that blend a little bit more into the
whole surroundings now that we also have
that rock work throughout this area and
um yeah going on to the station I
decided to experiment a little bit with
this as well so once again we have that
rock work as the sort of foundation and
then on top of that we have the the uh
the bezel pillars to basically function
as regular old pillars for a building
and normally they would also be used for
rock formations which come think of it
I've never actually used them for that
purpose and it would definitely be fun
to try that out someday as well because
that is basically what they're here for
um but you know they work very well for
this kind of thing as well and then on
the roof structure I'm working with
quarter tiles because it it allows you
to have all kinds of different color
variations in the texture as well which
makes everything a little bit more
interesting to look at and I think it
also fits with the look of the Rook work
walls with the basic pieces everywhere
and moving on here's another experiment
with these little Rook facade techniques
um I wanted to give the launch section
of the intimate launch coaster some
scenery and after thinking about it for
a while I figured we have this path
going underneath it so I definitely had
to add an arch underneath it there why
not just make this thing a row of arches
basically like a Roman architecture
basically like an old Roman aqueduct or
something like that and the colors and
the look of the arch pieces that are
already in the game I think fit very
well with the basic shape Rock work
structures it's all kind of Blocky it's
all different Shades of Gray
um so I decided to go with the solution
and it really just kind of looks like a
bridge and honestly I might want to
experiment with that a little bit in the
future and see if we can use it to make
real Roman aqueducts or
maybe it could be used in some sort of
French build I have no idea the annoying
thing about this game is that I keep
coming up with ideas that are not going
to fit into any scenario at any point in
the future
um and that I'm not really sure what to
do with because they also wouldn't fit
too easily into a theme park setting but
it is really fun to think about these
things and to experiment with all the
small pieces in park attacks and and
come up with things like this and in a
way it really reminds me of Lego because
you don't have to worry too much about
textures or anything like that you have
very small pieces to work with that you
can make things out of that generally
look like the thing that you're building
but always with a sense of suspense of
disbelief because obviously everything
looks minimalistic and cartoony and
blocky but you can see what it's going
for and in that sense it's a lot more
flexible than games like Planet coaster
because you use your imagination a
little bit more and things don't have to
be quite as real stick and I'm realizing
that I'm going quite off topic compared
to what I'm actually doing
um but yeah the whole idea for this area
turned out to be eventually to make it
look like one connected uh structure and
really try to blend the launch coaster
with the tilting coaster into one
thematic thing an area and
um also I was looking at the Old Town
ruins that we have in this scenario and
figuring that they don't really fit in
with the look of the things that I've
been building they're not quite as
detailed they don't have all of that
Greenery and stuff like that so I
decided to add some strawberry to the
buildings and some Vines and stuff like
that to really make them look like
they're not just ruined but nature is
slowly taking them over as well which I
think goes for many of the structures
the very idea of uh Celeste mountain and
I guess this is something I'm willing to
spoil because it's not really a spoiler
for the story or anything and you might
have been able to tell by just looking
at what this map looks like the idea of
Celeste mountain is that it's a mountain
that the main character wants to climb
and it's a mountain that has lots of
Forgotten and old ruined structures on
it so that's kind of a little bit of a
post-apocalyptic theme almost
um but yeah that's uh that's why I
decided to make it a little bit more
taken over by Nature
now moving on we have yet another
coaster because even though we don't
have to build a certain amount of
coasters in the scenario guests are
extra hard to attract to your Park and
the best way to attract guests is to
build high intensity High excitement
rating coasters
um plus there was one coaster type that
I haven't given a try yet in this
scenario so far at least which is the
steel coaster the good old Schwarzkopf
Looper
um and I figured I had just enough space
left between the launch coaster and the
rest of the hillside to fit in something
like this turns out I was more or less
right even though it also turned out to
be quite a puzzle to figure out how to
fit this thing in and eventually I came
up with this solution of building a loop
out of two half Loops to make this thing
fit in which is a little bit unusual and
you can tell that the shape is a little
bit strange but I think it more or less
Works partly because in real life
Schwarzkopf coasters sometimes have not
just circular Loops but also Loops that
really shift you to the side a lot more
than other Loops do which sometimes just
has to do with the way that their
layouts are designed to be transportable
coasters
um so I think it works in that sense but
also
I think that Loop doesn't actually look
too bad it really does look a little bit
more circular than the standard vertical
Loop in the game that's made out of one
piece so honestly as much as I was
skeptical about it making a loop out of
two half Loops in park Tech gives you a
loop with a different shape and that
shifts to the side a little bit more but
I think it works it's a very valid thing
to try and I'm pretty happy that I tried
it after six years of playing this game
you know you always keep learning stuff
and right after I decided to build that
layout I decided to build another
coaster and this is going to be the
final coaster for this scenario no
worries I'm not going to keep going
until the end of time I just figured
that I had all of these really intense
coasters and all of them with inversions
as well you know we have two Euro
Fighters we have a launch coaster with
inversions we have the Tilt coaster and
we have the steel looping coaster
these are all intense and I really
didn't have anything for the families
and I was looking at my coaster list and
realizing that the only decent option I
had was the mouse so I decided to build
that thing also in the meantime I
decided to build this elevator because
guests in the game can get pretty tired
from walking upstairs and I had this
little bit of space left over that I
thought would be interesting if you went
into the mountain and then up an
elevator that brings you out of the
Mountain at a different location
um interesting setup over there but I
think it just works in the layout of
this park because everything is getting
pretty crammed
um so yeah that's that also the wild
mouse coaster is a little bit inspired
by motherhorn Blitz in Europa Park which
also features a tower structure for the
lift hill with a special element inside
of it that I'm not going to spoil for
anybody who might be going to Europa
Park at some point in the future and
never seen a POV of that coaster I think
it's a little bit more fun if you don't
know what the coaster is like before you
ride it so there's a little tip for
anybody who's still wanting to go to
Europa Park but basically
um it has a lift system within a tower
and then it brings you up to the top and
then after that you have this more or
less regular Mouse layout that's
something that more or less works with
the structure that was already in this
scenario which is that fortress-like
structure so I decided to place that in
there and then
um yeah that's gonna have to be themed
at some later stage because for now I
decided it was time to get back to this
area where basically everything was
looking very burn and very boring and
add some interesting tidbits over here
as well now I'm not going to theme
anything too much I'm going to keep
everything pretty simple but I
definitely want to add some simple roofs
and decent looking fences and everything
here and there not just leave everything
up to the way that the that they look uh
in the game
also I decided to add an abundance of
Flags over here not for any particular
reason other than that it's a pretty
common object in Celeste
I don't know you can you can often find
lots of flags and uh waving cloths and
stuff like that in levels not sure how
that ended up on the mountain but I
decided to give a small nod to it with
some of the items around the park as
well
and then there's the roof of the kiosk
over here where I had no idea why I
decided to come up with this it just
looks pretty fun
um but that was that was my little idea
for the roof of that thing basically
also it wasn't too difficult to achieve
there's just so much stuff that you can
easily do with the basic shapes I'm I'm
very far from from done with
experimenting with those things now
moving on for the launch section of the
launch coaster we decided to add some
archways but for the break run of the
looping coaster I also figured it would
be cool to add some kind of theming
element and while the theme of Celeste
is nowhere near related to Aztec and
Mayan theming
for some reason I do get some Vibes of
that from some of the scenery and the
people who've played the game will know
what I'm talking about if you haven't
you'll definitely have no idea but
um I think for that reason the Adventure
theme and especially that portal kind of
fit it fits into the Celeste theme and
with a little bit of rock work around
the sides and the Cobblestone technique
it turns into a pretty fun portal into a
new part of the of the map and it
manages to finish that square with the
Clockwork flat ride in a sense give it
some kind of visual Anchor Point I feel
and also I wanted to give the elevator a
roof because just having that open
building and tunnel down underground it
just seemed a little bit weird I decided
to make this roof a little bit inspired
by the gem Jewel Shard looking things
that are all over the map and all over
Celeste as well
um so that's what that strange look is
if I had some kind of hexagon shaped
items I would have used them but given
that everything is square and we don't
have hexagon shape basic shapes this is
the best I could come up with to make it
look somewhat like a gemstone
um so you guys are gonna have to accept
this honestly I'm not super happy with
it but I think it works in the space and
the color fits into this area we didn't
really have this color yet for any of
the roofs but you can definitely see
this very light green blue-ish green
um color in some other parts of the park
so it's good to keep those things coming
back
then there's this entrance Into the
Heart of the mountain on the side here
where for a while I was considering
putting an underground coaster there
just in case I wouldn't be able to reach
the minimum guest requirements by the
end of the scenario but at this point
I'm pretty sure that I'm gonna get there
if I just start campaigning you know
right now I haven't reached 800 guests
yet but with a little bit of
advertisement I think it shouldn't be
too hard to get there so at this point I
decided to just put a food court in
there because people were complaining
more and more about the lack of food and
drinks in the park which does make a lot
of sense because if you're at this side
of the park you really have to walk all
over and up and down the mountain to get
to the other side to get to where my
food court is
um so yeah the newest food court is
underground which is also nice because
it makes it much easier to hide some of
the backstage things that I had to put
in there to make sure that we can get
Goods delivered to those stores so all
in all I think it's a pretty decent
solution
now coming to the final section of
making this scenario I wanted to theme
the uh wild mouse coaster and the steel
coaster a little bit more because for a
while I was considering leaving this
whole snowy area completely snowy and
empty but eventually I opted against it
so I just went with my trusty old
Cobblestone technique and putting a
bunch of grass patches in here to add
some foliage to it because I mostly
wanted to stick to a little rule to
myself to not Place foliage on the snowy
bits of the mountain
so instead of doing that I unsnowied
some of the parts using this and now I
have an excuse to put lots of foliage on
these green bits and keep the white bits
in between mostly empty maybe put a
little bit of work work there in there
and also maybe some scenery elements but
there's not going to be too many trees
on there so definitely if you zoom out
and you look at the terraforming you can
see that basically appear as a theme
throughout the map all of the foliage is
around buildings and on special areas
and wherever there's gray ground but no
snow and all of the snowy bits are
mostly
uncovered up
so uh
uncovered up yeah I guess I guess not
covered up
basically so
um also I wanted to theme these coasters
a little bit more to the game
specifically and here I'm also going to
try and refrain from talking about any
particular characters or things in the
game but do know that the things that
I'm building are heavily inspired by
stuff that you can find in the game and
I guess here I would like to say if you
know you know and if you don't
you know it's uh it's still something
that I think kind of looks pretty neat
so the steel coaster here didn't really
have a lot of scenery around it at least
not as much as the launch coaster and
especially the Tilt coaster so I decided
to add this Frame around the start of
the ride and also at another spot to
really give it its own scenery to
interact with it's pretty minimalistic
and it's a minimalistic rendition of
something that appears in the game
but I figured it was a reference that
fit into this whole area especially and
also I wanted to fit a kind of similar
reference at the at the back side of the
loop and this is going to be kind of
inspired by
um incredit coaster which has that
backdrop behind the Loop and when it
used to be California screaming it had
that Mickey Mouse theming I think it was
behind the Loop and I think the idea of
having a circular backdrop behind the
Loop is really cool and it's something
that works in this case because we have
that path leading down into the mountain
with a view of the loop and supposedly
it would also have a view of one I'm
building behind this here
so that was my little project for this
area to make this whole map look a
little bit more celeste-ish so while the
theming is not very direct or or very
obvious I would say for this map in
general uh
it's really the kind of stuff where if
you know what it is you'll be able to
recognize it and otherwise it's just
some uh some loose theming now that does
make me really curious because I've been
recommending Celeste a bunch of times in
this video and talking about it a bunch
but how many people have actually played
it
um so I don't know leave leave a comment
if you've played Celeste and what you
think of the game because I would
suspect that given my audience and the
fact that I'm into simulation and
creative games there's not a huge
overlap there
um but you know
sometimes the world is surprising and
many people who like video games play a
broad range of video games as do I it's
just this creative stuff that I upload
to my YouTube channel
and speaking of which I had this last
minute idea of adding some extra scenery
to the wild mouse because I really
couldn't come up with anything to do
here
um these are also inspired by stuff in
the game and honestly
I'm not talking about it much because I
don't want to spoil anything but at the
same time I also wouldn't be able to
explain what these things are because
I'm still not entirely sure it just has
a particular look and I think it's
pretty interesting and I decided to add
it to this area especially because we
already have that red color in the wild
mouse and it's uh it's pretty iconic for
the game so once again if you know you
know and otherwise here's just me
playing with a bunch of basic shapes to
make some interesting looking weird
scenery around the wild mouse coaster
so that is basically it for this
scenario at this point I was looking at
everything and thinking you know I can
come up with one last thing maybe one
last thing to really make this map
recognizably Celeste while not giving it
too many direct references and to
anybody who's played video games this is
probably pretty recognizable it's it
spikes the game has spikes and I don't
know I figured I could put these things
on some Cobblestone structures slap them
around the area here and there
um and you know if you fall off one of
these coasters you're basically screwed
I suppose but at the same time it's a
very typical Celeste looking block even
though you find it in many many video
games uh Celeste does a very particular
way of using these things so that was my
final little addition to the park and
with that said
I think we're about to reach the goal so
let's see how the park is doing and have
a small overview of the entire build
alright so here we Are we almost reached
the goal of 800 guests in the park and
I'm not sure if I need to hope this goal
for a couple of months or if I'm just
instantly gonna win the scenario but I
suppose we're gonna see at any point
right now
um
I have everything right that's the only
goal we need awesome there we go cool so
uh that's that over with uh now let's
take a look at all of the coasters and
stuff uh first of all Let's uh give the
launch coaster it's right
um let's get rid of the menu as well so
it has that funny bit where it has a
hydraulic launch right after the station
which means that it's kind of strangely
jutting out of the station at the start
of the layout uh but we're well on our
way and going through the Norwegian Loop
and having some interaction over here
with the steel coaster I mean I mean the
steel looping coaster technically I
guess that's the name in roller coast
Tycoon anyway point is when you build
all of these coasters next to each other
you get that awesome interaction here
and there which to me as a theme park
nerd is one of the most glorious things
you can find anywhere whether it be
roller coasters or trains and cars and
planes and stuff like that interaction
is always cool now let's move on to uh
our
um what's it called again
the tilting coaster there we go
uh obviously of course that's what this
thing is called
um which is a bit of a strange coaster
to film I suppose because you can really
tell that the layout is really broken up
by this little in the middle section
there's always a debate between
different coaster Enthusiast factions
whether a little on the middle of the
ride is a good or a bad addition there
are many people who are fans of good
pacing in the layouts and find a
break-in pacing to be a negative part of
a coaster but honestly I feel like it's
it's really fun to have a small pause in
the action in the middle of the layout
and with a coaster like this especially
you know it gives you something and then
it gives you a moment to look forward to
that crazy drop track over there uh that
that it's not really a drop track it's a
it's a tilting track I guess that's what
the element would be called
um but yeah I think it's a it's a fun
way to make a layout especially the way
that this layout is built on the
hillside so by the time we reach the
height of the station uh it's it's
slowed down quite significantly and we
just have a small curve back into the
station over here so that's the uh the
tilting coaster honestly is it tilting
coaster or tilt coaster because I keep
saying tilting but it's it's a tilt
coaster look I know very little about
things like this I know in the last
episode I got my dive loops and
immelman's wrong also thanks everybody
for the tips on how to keep the two
apart I remember from a bunch of
comments the dive Loop is something that
you dive into so you first have to dive
and then the half Loop and a dive of
course is the kind of twisting motion
although you could make the argument
that a half Loop is also just a really a
diving element but for now at least dive
Loop is a good way to remember um which
is which and then the immelman will just
be the other elements in my head so to
speak
now moving on to the steel looping
coaster over here which
honestly I'm just gonna take some time
on the lift Hill and see what this thing
is officially called again because as
per usual I'm mixing up all kinds of
different names partly that's also
because things have different names in
the game I'm very tempted to call this
the Swatch cup Looper anytime I look at
it but of course in the game it's not
known as the Swatch cuff Looper and it
is known as a steel coaster I guess I
got it right the first time
doesn't matter too much in my head it's
the the steel looping coaster anyway and
here's the layouts with a little bit of
slow Meandering around the wild mouse
coaster here and then this drop into the
lower section of the layout honestly
this thing doesn't really have any major
large drops it just has a layout that
builds more and more speed as you move
down the Hillside and finally head into
the loop over here
which is funnily shaped but it really
works out I think with the two half
loops and then after that Loop we
quickly turn back into the station so I
think this is a layout with really good
pacing in terms of the the variety of
elements and the order that they're in I
think it's just about a best case
scenario we have a small appetizer
before the lift Hill and then we slowly
build up more and more speed as we head
toward the climax of The Ride which is
this Loop of course
and in terms of intensity I think this
could reasonably be a family coaster
even though we do have the loop in there
these kind of Swatch cup looping
coasters tend to be not quite as intense
as Arrow or for Comas or at least
they're more comfortable their Loops
tend to be more intense but the rest of
the layout is pretty mild
and man these things are so much fun I
remember riding revolution in Six Flags
Magic Mountain which kind of does a
similar thing it has a very long-winded
layout that just makes its way through
the hillside until you have the loop
which is almost at the end of the layout
so I feel like they're very similar in a
sense
now finally let's take a look at the
wild mouse and I just realized we have
so many coasters in this map
uh let's get a car that's actually
I have another plan
we're gonna wait for that car for the
for the next car I suppose to come out
of the the hillside part
it's a bit unfortunate that it's it's
kind of hard to select exactly which car
you want but here we go we got there
uh as per usual it's not really anything
too special uh it does well Mouse stuff
lots of hairpin turns and a few drops in
between but the layout is pretty unusual
for this type of poster we have the
layout going through many different
areas and not really being restricted to
one compact part of the park
um plus we have the ending which is a
little bit strange where it dips down
into a crazy turn and then we break at
the end honestly it's a bit strange but
I just couldn't figure out what else to
do with this coaster that wouldn't look
out of place
um and I'm glad I did because it also
means that I could have the steel
coaster interact with the wild mouse
coaster here which is pretty cool and
um yeah something that I generally like
trying to do in my Parks is having
different areas that are very crammed
and very busy and then some other areas
that are a bit more spread out and less
dense and to me at least that creates
the ideal feeling of flow throughout a
theme park now I find it very difficult
to get a comprehensive view of how this
park is laid out because the colors are
a little bit unusual of the terrain we
have a lot of gray and white not a lot
of foliage so it's definitely a very
different looking Park so I don't know
how happy I am with how it turned out
it's not my favorite scenario in terms
of looks but this was a really fun
scenario to work on and I am very happy
with the layouts of The Coasters so I
guess there's a little bit of something
in every scenario and it's always a
little bit different also I am pretty
happy with the way that the Celeste
themes are
um yeah incorporated into this park
anybody who's played Celeste hopefully
will recognize some of the elements and
I want to close this video by saying
that I've been playing Celeste almost
the entire game again recently and it
reminded me just of how good that game
is so if you haven't played it yet
definitely go give it a try if you're
into Platformers or if you're interested
into interesting storylines or both
honestly it's a great game and
definitely well worth the try anyway
that's gonna be it for this episode so
I'm gonna quickly save this park and
head down to the menu
and we'll see what our trophy is going
to be well of course it's the house at
the start of the scenario I think that's
a very fitting trophy for this map
and that's when we moved to
oh we got the rocket I think we can
click it during the animation and it'll
just it'll have to come back yeah it
does
that's cool
and also very fitting because the next
episode is going to take place on the
moon
so yeah I'm gonna leave it at this for
now thank you guys for watching and I'll
see you next time bye